it's important to research women in
smoking because women face significant
health disparities with regards to the
tobacco use what you find is that women
are more likely to develop serious
health consequences as a result of
smoking for example they're more likely
to experience cardiac disease and more
likely to develop lung cancer when
compared to men also women are less
likely to be able to quit smoking so
there's been national surveys that have
been conducted every year for the last
50 years and in every single year women
it's shown that women are less able to
quit smoking when compared to men much
of the research focuses on the benefits
of quitting so of course you're going to
improve your health you're going to save
money etc but women acknowledge and
experience significant risks associated
with quitting so they say if I quit
smoking I'm going to be less able to
manage my stress I'm going to gain
weight and so if women do try to quit
these risks are also associated with
less success in quitting smoking so
we've been targeting these risks in
terms of treatment development and
trying to develop more effective
treatments for women
it's important to do research on sex
differences in gender differences in
tobacco use and in depression because
there are clear differences in how men
and women are able to quit smoking and
how they how often they experience
depression and depression like symptoms
there's double the prevalence of
depression in women and therefore it's
clear that having a basic science model
of how that happens will point us in the
direction of novel treatments and that
interaction with smoking is something
that is quite complex and one that
really also impinges on how to help
women quit smoking as opposed to men we
know for example that nicotine
replacement strategies are much more
effective in men than in women and we
know that there are novel treatments
that also treat the effect of the the
depression like symptoms that come along
with quitting smoking and that can help
a physician choose which kinds of
treatments are going to be useful for
men and which for women
osteoporosis is such a common problem in
women it carries with it a huge risk
women who suffer a hip fracture have
about a twenty percent chance of dying
in the first year after hip fracture
nearly fifty percent of women over the
age of 50 will have some sort of
osteoporosis related fracture in their
lifetime and we don't really understand
completely the factors that put women at
greater risk the work currently funded
by women's health research at Yale has
broad implications most of the drugs we
have now slow the rate of bone breakdown
but don't build up new bone this work
would open the possibility of a new way
to treat low bone density millions of
women in the united states already have
low bone density and we need better and
safer ways to address that problem
our Center has emphasized the importance
of studying women the importance of
studying gender differences and we have
tapped into a genuine interest in
science in knowing more about women's
health and gender differences
improvement in the health and health
care of everyone depends upon the
translation of empirical findings into
personal and professional practice
particularly as we look ahead to the
various kinds of hurdles that we face
with regard to the health care of the
nation it's critically important that we
start to infuse gender specific medicine
into our healthcare systems and take
advantage of what we know to improve the
health of everyone
you